you know how with conspiracy theories  we're like just about to get all the  data it's all about to come out this guy  Mike pillow who makes pillows has been  saying for two years it's all about to  come out his cyber guys have done a  cyber Symposium I don't know I think it  means Symposium and it's all about to  come out and it never does okay many  people have been saying that sort of  stuff with the JFK assassination but  there is a particular guy Jefferson  Morley who I've interviewed on the  program who is announcing a major break  in the assassination story of JFK and he  has a date that's very soon December  15th December 15th based on an October  2021 memo President Biden will have  federal agencies disclose all records  related to the assassination now there  are many people who are saying this is  it this is finally going to be the thing  that blows wide open the JFK  assassination story  I'm open to hearing it